so you can start with prayers roger
um i haven't actually got prayers down
on my agenda but uh i assumed did i see
claire earlier
yes hi would you like to lead us in
prayers
yes love to yeah lovely to see everybody
happy new year although it's a bit late
so let us pray
let us commend ourselves to god who is
able to do
far more than we can say do
or think we pray to god
who alone makes us dwell in safety
for all who are affected by the ongoing
coronavirus pandemic
through illness or isolation or
anxiety that they
may find relief and recovery
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
for those who guide our nation
that they may make decisions with wisdom
and understanding
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
for this council that all decisions may
be made
wisely and with caring concern
for our communities
we thank you lord for the way the
council has worked
closely to support local businesses with
various grants
and the way they have initiated vaccine
centers
reached out to those in the tourist
industry
with help and also
offered support to the most vulnerable
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
for medical practitioners and
researchers
that through their bravery and insight
many will be restored to health
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
for all whose work obliges them to
travel
delivering essential goods and services
that they may be sustained and protected
as they play a vital role in maintaining
daily life
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
for the vulnerable and the fearful
for the gravely ill and the dying
that they may know comfort and peace
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
let us commend ourselves and all for
whom we pray
to the mercy and protection of god
o gracious and holy father give us
wisdom to perceive you
diligence to seek you
patience to wait for you
a heart to meditate upon you
and a life to proclaim you
through the power of the spirit of jesus
christ our lord
thank you amen right i'll start the
agenda proper now
uh item one on the agenda apologies for
absence do we have any
councillor rossi sends his apologies
okay sorry chair we'll take a register
of attendance
first just so we can committee clerks
know who's at the meeting
so if mary you could take that for me
please
[Music]
council abouten right here thank you
councillor bright here
councillor brown yeah here councillor
bushby
here council christie yeah
councilman clark here
councillor cottle hunkin she's literally
just joining
yeah okay craigie
yeah councillor dart
here councillor ford here
councillor gob here
councillor hackett here councillor james
yeah sorry councillor harding yeah
councillor hawkins here
councillor apple yeah councillor hicks
here council hudson here
councillor hurley president councillor
hutchins
yeah counselling here
councillor james here councillor jones
yeah councillor langford
here councillor laws present
council of leather yeah councillor lock
mckenzie president
councillor manly present
councillor newton president
thank you thank you
um i'll go back then as uh item one on
the agenda are there any apologies
apologies from councillor brenton and
councillor rossi
thank you uh i'll move on then to item
two
council minutes this is a meeting held
on the 14th of december i'll go through
them
uh page by page so page four
page five page six
page seven page eight
page 9 page 10
page 11 page 12 page 13
page 14 page 15
page 16.
17 page 18 page 19 and page 20.
nobody's raised their hand so from the
chat i'll propose we accept those is
there a seconder or counselor watson
[Applause]
yes i'll second it here thank you
but uh nobody said in it can we go to
the vote then to accept those
of course councillor bowton four
councillor bright or councillor brown
or council of the bush bee or
council christie or councillor clark
or councillor cardiff hankin
councillor craigie i love staying
because i wasn't there
thank you council dart
for councillor ford
four counselor cup
paul councillor hackett or
councillor haynes
thank you council harding or
councillor hawkins or councillor
for council hicks
or councillor hudson oh
councillor harley or councillor
hutchings
or councillor inch
for councillor james paul
councillor jones
or councillor langford
for council of laws
or councillor mckenzie
four councillor manly
i'll abstain mary i wasn't present
councillor newton four
councillor pennington or
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
i'll abstain thank you
thank you i'll move on then uh item
three on the agenda public contributions
i have none
uh item four declarations of interest
you all know about those
item five agreement of agenda items part
one and two there is nothing in part two
item six uh consider correspondence i've
had none at all obviously i've come to
the table rather late i don't think
there is
any i don't know if steve's got anything
urgent but uh
chair nothing right thank you all right
item seven there have been no written
questions
so i'll go on to automate and i think it
is it mr keely mark
chair there there's a written question
is that
oh sorry
it's been uh tom circulated it uh
earlier on and he's put the uh question
and the answer up on the screen for you
from councillor jones
fascinating council jones said do you
have a subsidiary question
thank you chair um yeah i thought this
was an interesting question to
raise um as we've all been doing our
remote meetings now
for for this period of time and uh
taking out the member training expenses
we can see that the difference
uh during this period was ten thousand
nine hundred and eighty four pounds
which is
a considerable saving so um given that
there are clear financial
benefits um from
uh having remote meetings and then it
gives us potentially the ability to
modernize the way we conduct our
business
which could even lead to a more
representative council by allowing
a greater flexibility which would mean
that potentially more working people
could participate
my question is whether the leader will
join me in seeking online meetings in
the future
if it is within our competence to do so
thank you
thank you i don't know if you want to
say anything about that ken at the
moment
um well no um i'm quite happy with uh
the meetings i understand
at the moment the legislation covering
soon meetings ronzo
in may and i understand the lga have
been trying to get clearance from the
government
or clarity from the government as to
whether it will continue and at the
moment they are not
committing themselves one way or the
other but there has been
influence that they would like to go
back to face to face but at the moment
it's very vague um so i think it's going
to be a
wait and see but obviously because it is
by uh legislation
that will have to come before parliament
when
the current legislation runs over
thank you thank you for raising that
council jones i suspect many of us have
wondered about that
i'll move on then uh item eight on the
agenda
uh i think i've got mark keely down uh
from one small step i believe is going
to give us a presentation
uh mr keely
i'll get there eventually there you go
mark if i meet you
i'm unmuted that was my problem i saw i
was on mute
i could be the least of my problems can
i share my screen now
tom yeah yes you can yeah i've removed
my presentation mark
okay
[Music]
good evening everybody and thank you for
letting me into your meeting this
evening
um my name is mark keeley i'm the
community engagement network lead for
northern devon
for one small step which is devin's
healthy lifestyle service
before i get into the meat of the
presentation i'd like to just think
about
how many times have you or members of
your family or people that you've come
across
uh friends relatives colleagues
ever thought about i'd like to get a
little bit healthier
now that might be about losing a few
pounds
it might be around
reducing the amount of alcohol you
intake it might be about
moving a bit more getting a bit more
active
and incidentally those three are linked
because if you move more
and you drink less then you're probably
going to lose weight
and of course the best thing that you
can ever do for your um
health is quit smoking so i suppose
if you've thought about quitting smoking
you either have or you haven't
and so let's get into the um
presentation shall we
but just have a think about those and i
think the um
one small step is possibly a way that
you could go if you feel
that this is appropriate for you or
anybody that you know
all right so introducing one small step
one small step is a free service to
support devon residents to improve their
health and well-being
and it's free to anyone in devon over
the age of 18.
and with the exception of our smoking
pathway
which fortunately we can accept anyone
who is 12 years and over
we can help people maintain a healthy
weight we can
help people get more active we can help
people reduce their alcohol intake
and of course we can help people quit
smoking we offer
this information advice and guidance
available online
by telephone and in normal times
non-coveted times
we offer a face-to-face support as well
so what do we offer one-to-one behavior
change support
our health trainers and our stop smoking
advisors are available to support
clients to make changes
to their lifestyles this support is
currently
due to covid only available by telephone
we also signpost people we can signpost
clients to a range of services
and opportunities in the local area so
if you're
interested in losing weight we could
tell you where your local slimming world
is where your local weight watchers
is if you're interested in getting
fitter
in non-covered times we could tell you
where your local gym is but obviously we
can't do that now
but we can't tell you any um
opportunities that are
up and running like your local um
walking valve events that take
place in victoria park not too sure if
they're going at the moment whether
they're
sort of covered restrictions safe or not
but that's what we could do in normal
times for people
and we keep a directory of services that
can cut across the whole of that board
um self-help online support is available
via our website and social media places
our health trainers know how hard it can
be to make a lifestyle change
and they can help clients to set goals
to put a healthy lifestyle into easier
reach
working with a health trainer can help
people to take back control of their own
health
in their own time and on their own terms
health trainers and this is really
important they'd really like to listen
to their clients they like to get hold
of the client's story
and understand their needs and help them
to prioritize a personal plan
they can also help find the right
support and advice on a local
from local organizations all designed to
help them
to take those first steps to a happier
and healthier life
the services client-led and flexible
that's really important to us
it's up to six sessions and uses a range
of evidence-based behavior change
strategies
to support clients to achieve long-term
lifestyles
stop smoking service clients can access
one-to-one support from our dedicated
stop smoking practitioners
obviously like with the health trainers
this is
telephone support only at this moment in
time we also are able to arrange for
clients to receive the best nicotine
replacement therapy products
including gum nasal spray patches
on the description from their gps or
provide it directly
free of charge if they are eligible
we can also provide stop smoking
medications such as shampex
these products will help manage cravings
and withdrawal symptoms
which people can often suffer when
they're giving up smoking
the service offers a 12-week smoking
cessation program
follows the national center for smoking
cessation treatment
guidelines
our online support you go to our website
www.onesmallstep.org uk
provides information about our pathways
for our clients
gps health professionals and other
stakeholders and anybody else really
that would fancy
um logging onto our website
and just exploring what's there to
support making healthier
lifestyle changes self-help packs are
available to download
they contain tools such as food and
physical activity diaries
quit smoking diaries and apps that you
can download
there's always an app somewhere in this
world nowadays isn't there and we've got
a few that you can download if you wish
to
uh it allows people across devon to
request a call back from us
the service and for professionals to
make referrals
there are also resources for healthcare
professionals to access as well
so our social media you can find us on
facebook instagram
and twitter now hopefully if the
technology allows me i'll play i'm
aiming to play you
a mainly to give you a break from my
monotone voice going on and on
no we can't see anything mark or hear
anything
can you hear it no all right that's
um absolutely technology has defeated me
right then let me see if i can
get back to where we were well that's
that's a shame
because china tells us although she yeah
she tells us about what a unit is
and it gives you a break from my voice
um so
never mind i'm gonna have to have a look
into that and see how we can fix it for
future presentations
and i apologize to you all for that so
moving on swiftly
um accessing one small step there are a
number of ways you can contact the
service
self-referral is the main way in um
you can call 01392-908-139
that's a obviously a local number and a
local rates
um hello at one small step if you email
us
our hello numbers really really good
sometimes i think in these um
modern technology times you often see
info at all hello act
and you write into them and they just
seem to go into the
ether and you never get any replies from
them but oh hello
at one small step um service is really
good i'd probably get
three or four um inquiries a week from
it
um sometimes it's even more than that so
it really works
um if you wish to give up smoking uh you
can
text the word quit to the number six
zero treble or
there's a contact form contact me form
that you can complete on our website um
and we will get back to you within 48
hours
or 72 hours if it's like a bank holiday
or a weekend time
professionals can refer clients via our
website
using the
https onesmallstep.org.uk
professionals to professional referral
form and again we will get back to
if if you fill that in when you're
sitting well i suppose at all to say oh
i did a professionals it's really quite
worldwide
so if you happen to be sitting with
someone and they mentioned
that they would you know like to change
their lifestyle in any way
then if you can log on to this page and
log on to our website
and you can use that
to get that person in touch with us
really quickly
if you see on the bottom right hand side
there make a referral
so you can fill that in and we will get
back to that person within 48 hours
or 72 if it's a weekend or a bank
holiday
um so that works really well at the
moment promoting that really
interestingly
um as i said interestingly making every
contact count is a course that we run
and i know a couple of people have been
on it
that are listening in tonight one small
step is one of devon providers for mech
training
mech is about giving people the skills
and confidence
to have healthy conversations with
people
is an approach that is used by millions
of
day-to-day interactions that
organizations and
individuals have with people to support
them in making
positive changes to both their physical
and mental health
and well-being so that point i was
saying right back at the beginning
you know how many times have we had
conversations with people when you say
how are you today and someone looks
around and says oh i wish i could give
out the [ __ ]
or i should really not drink so much i'm
putting on a few pounds or
put on a few pounds over christmas might
have been
conversations you'd have had in the last
month or two with people
uh the last month actually it's not been
two months since christmas has it
so it's a possibility and for you to get
onto our emac
light this is available free of charge
to frontline workers
and again we would include yourselves
within that light within that
bunch of people from a range of
organizations
it's delivered over three hours it's a
zoom session
it's free it's certificated it's
um endorsed by the
royal society of health professionals
and so when have we got them we've got
them coming up in february
on the 16th um
10 till 1 in the morning and then we've
got another one in march
on the 17th of march and that's a
and that's again from 10 until 10 in the
morning until 1 in the afternoon
and that's free
so if you would like to get involved
with that i can send you the details
in the near future actually this week
probably
thank you for listening any questions
those are my contact deals details if
you wish to get hold of them
mark i'll just say because the
presentation get some issues
i'll circulate it to all counsellors for
you tomorrow morning
oh thank you very much tom that's
excellent thank you yeah thank you tom
yeah thank you mark for that um i
haven't got anybody asking any questions
but
i suspect we're all going to wait to see
the uh presentation when tom sends it
out
so thank you okay so you couldn't see
the presentation at all
no wow
no no no no no
what went wrong there then i'm sure
we'll sort it out so
i'm going to move on to the agenda
actually and uh please do
just thank you very much for all your
time and um
thank you for listening for listening to
me and it was just listening to me
um so thank you for your time much
appreciated
thank you um
i'm just trying to i seem to have lost
my
oh now i've got it back blue hand yes uh
right
uh i'll go on then item nine on the
agenda lead member structure
um this i presume steve hearst is taking
this
steve which i believe the leader
is but i'll be corrected if not
yeah i think it was meant to be me steve
um
and chair right thank you um
you're all well aware that with the
changes from chief exec downwards we've
restructured
uh most of the management into providing
more
direct lines of communication
and responsibility and with that we have
now looked at the
lead members roles um the constitution
says that we
should have 10 i think at the moment um
so we've stuck with that number
and what we've tried to do partially
successfully
is to align individual members to
individual officers
so that we don't have lots of members
worrying lots of officers and and and
people not knowing exactly who is
responsible for what
so before you on page 24
is the the list that we've come up with
um and the main main changes
are that um we uh
cancer hudson with a passion for
finance and audit is taking that on as a
lead role
and that is obviously going to be very
important to us as we go through
um the unwinding from the kovac
situation coverage situation and also
the various grants we've given um
so she will be doing finance and that
some of her stuff has gone to
council hicks to do it with under the
economy
planner and the property banner um
and i've took on
i'm going to be working with john walter
on ice
the ict and developing better
communication and also doing some work
with
um sarah on uh communications
because i seem to be forever agreeing to
statements and and
trying to keep this council in front um
so that we're letting our communities
know what's going on
uh and so hackett will be taking on the
environment i've had a query tonight
about
it being environmental and environmental
protection
and i will look at that over the next
couple of days
um so where we are now is that we will
be looking
steve will be working from the officer
side and i will be working from member
side
so that we can get some cohesion between
um
the mem lead member and the officer in
that department in that section
um so that we can work towards
delivering um which will be part of my
remit with john
walter to delivering this um
the strategy that we've came up with
which seems a long time ago now
to deliver that within the policies that
we are working to
so that we will get a much better
communication
and then once we've done that we are
looking at ways of ensuring
we do report back to leaders meetings
which is part two
but we would like to report a
not a summary but a non-part two version
of what um is happening to
all councillors although obviously if
they want to know what's in part two
they can attend leaders meetings anyway
so that will give everybody a much more
informed
idea of where we're going as a council i
have picked up in the last week or so
that there are some changes going on at
other councils
and i think our structure and the way
we're dealing with it
has been looked at and has been quite
well received
so i would just like to make the
proposed recommend the recommendation
steve wants to come in and say anything
before we do that but i will do the
recommendation
i can't remember what i wrote
the recommendation was the members
approved the following
amended lead members structure and lead
members
oh second thank you doug seconded by
council on my agenda i do have uh
it says receive the report of the leader
and chief executive i don't know if
steve wants to say anything
um uh not not particularly chair the the
leaders covered most things
obviously the key thing is uh lead
members and the officer structure
working together
looking at service planning business
planning make sure everything kind of
feeds through from the
strategic plan that members uh adopted
recently so
okay i've got nothing further i had the
only thing
come to james i think you might want to
add the the north devon
plus bit of the recommendation as well
and talk
talks briefly about that if you like
yeah yeah
just to apologize for that um coach
hackett
having taken on my environmental role
traditionally
in the um the north seven plus
um the leader has often been on that so
um
we looked at that and um i will be
taking on the role
with joe um on north devon plus
um because that is playing a bigger role
and we need to
um it has got um fair influence and we
will be driving north devon plus forward
so that that's included in the
recommendation
that i will be taking on north seven
plus all right
thank you i've got a list of speakers uh
councillor mcgoff you're first
yeah thank you very much mr chairman um
thank you very much ken
for your report there um i'd move
straight to the recommendation on the
back the environment
i personally believe that the
environment should be a separate entity
all on its own
such a major issue going forward within
torres and we did all sign up to climate
emergency
i don't want to see it tied in with
climate change together because
obviously council ames has
got a lifetime of that that you know
that is an absolute pandora's box
unfortunately
so i'd like to propose counselor steve
hardin
who is a comes from an agricultural
background
and i think it's very important that we
actually adhere to an all-inclusive
council
which this council agreed to when you
first voted in you said you want to be
more inclusive
and to give representation from the
conservative party on there would be
very grateful for us
and it's a huge huge role the
environment uh steve is very willing to
do this
and i feel to me i feel he's the best
man for the job that's not undermining
nobody
council hackett is a very busy
counsellor you know you see him
absolutely everywhere what he does
you know he's very hard working i'm not
running down at all
when it comes down to number two the
north devon plus
ken you're the best man for the job the
leader should sit on that anyway
and i you know i do thank you for that
position i know you've got a busy role
yourself
you know you do you're doing well keep
it up but
to see you on that role as a lead member
there that's not on the
north seven plus is actually paramount
for our accounts are going forward but
i honestly like to encourage councils
now to spread the environment as a
separate entity
and also i propose councillor steve
harden
thank you thank you council mcgoff
before i go into the next speaker
i think uh council of james when you
talk about this you said our
constitution allows for 10
lead members council mcguff is now
suggesting an 11th is that correct
i would have to just check that that's
what we were working to i don't know
whether stacy knows
offhand um or even steve but i i thought
i read somewhere
that um we were a low in 10
um so i'm not sure where we'll go with
that
um station correct me if i am wrong but
we are at full council so if you're
proposing an amendment to the
constitution so if it does say
uh 10 in the constitution then as as
we're at full council um
you could propose as counselor mcgraw
has done so
an amendment to that um thank you
is there a second er for councilman goss
yes i would check in that thank you
councillor newton thank you i'll go into
the next speaker i've got councillor
hayes next
thank you chad yeah just first of all
picking up on what councilman goff said
i i'm a bit
disturbed about that proposal really
because
in my role for the lead member for
climate change i understood that covers
the natural and man-made environment
really
um including biodiversity um
i'm a bit of a loss to comprehend what
the separate
role would cover really um
having said that i wanted to go on and
just also express my concern about
to the lead member appointments um
councillor james and councillor hudson
they at the moment they do a huge amount
of work they have meetings practically
every hour a day as i understand it
i don't really understand why it's a
good idea for them to take on
even more responsibility um
i would have thought that we should be
looking to
other councillors to see if they're
prepared to take on
the roles really and i would
sort of propose that we
approve the um amended lead member
structure except for
the positions for council james and
hudson
and until we um until we've investigated
whether there are other candidates
amongst the
other councillors for those roles
nothing against council hodson and james
i think they're just doing amazing work
i just
can't really understand why they should
be taking on more work really
thank you chairman thank you uh we'll
come back and ask them in a minute
um councillor pennington thank you sir i
uncles much of the comments of counselor
golf
um i actually spoke to our leader
previous to this meeting about
the environmental protection on page 24
without having the environment
listed separately i would like to see if
the constitution allows it
to have the environment separated out
from environment
protection and i wouldn't be against
having a member to look at the
environment in its own right
i'm not against councillor harding
standing
and if there is not but i would like
other people to put their name in the
hat
if the council goes down the line of
having a uh
environment uh uh
a lead member on its own right equally
our leader did say he will look at it
again it's a bit woolly if you leave it
from that point of view
i would just like to know how he means
and if we vote for him this way tonight
um can we have the environment and
environmental protection
separated at a later stage should we
leave it till our agm if we're going to
have one in may
to sort this matter out thank you chair
thank you uh councillor newton i think
you're next
yeah thank you chair yes i was just
returning to
councillor mcgos original point um
and again absolutely nothing against the
the individual who holds the post
however councillor hackett's portfolio
is enormous already and as a member of
the
oversight and security uh scrutiny
external committee we hear councillor
hackett who reports to us
and if one cuts the the soft language
um community safety is policing
and well-being in health is the nhs and
those two
in their own are huge briefs if they're
covered properly
so i find it um
rather alarming that yet more is being
placed
on councillor hackett's portfolio where
i would
suggest that he's probably certainly
well loaded already if not overloaded
so i would strongly support environment
which doesn't necessarily link with
climate change
no um but um
i would strongly support that being
placed separately
and certainly not been added to what i
would consider
to be the already rather full portfolio
of of counselor hackett
uh thank you chad thank you
uh councillor harding
thank you chair yeah yeah thank you um
uh councillor mcgough for uh nominate me
as a
it was quite uh quite nice um basically
yes i do
um take a great interest in in the uh um
environment i mean i've been working in
our culture and farming
in my own right for 40 years and um
basically uh you know i'm now uh
working back um my son's taking over
most of it and my brother so
i'm now um busy laying hedges
stonewalling gardening and things like
that so i'm not only uh
um you know big on the the um uh
environment i work in it is my
livelihood um
yeah i've worked with the environmental
agency uh when
they were introducing otters and um
trying to get the uh
salmon to come up the rivers and uh so i
was heavily involved with them and the
big
river clean out and uh yeah i just think
um
it is a separate thing i think i think
you and
with a lot of uh i think uh you know you
to deal with landowners
and i know most of the landowners so uh
yeah you know
i just thought i i i agree with mr
mcgoff
cancer golf thank you thank you i do
have another speaker but
um our head of legal has put a hand up
would you like to come in now stacy if
you want to
answer any of those points yes um thank
you chair just just as a point of
clarity i've checked the constitution in
relation to
uh lead members um it doesn't stipulate
um
a number it just states that um it's up
to full council to approve
lead members i think as councillors
james has said we've historically had
had the term which is where we are we
are but
in terms of numbers in the constitution
um
it just states it's up to full council
to approve
thank you uh i'll go on then councillor
holmes
well thanks for letting me come back um
yeah i fully appreciate
cancer harding's enthusiasm and uh fully
appreciate his experience um
i just feel that if there is going to be
this new role then it should be
very clearly defined so that it doesn't
sort of
so it's has so separate um
as a separate role from climate change
really so
obviously i mean in terms of recycling
for instance they
that crosses over climate change but i
do think
you know the environment that should be
defined and clearly set out
when um when the role is uh formed
thank you thank you well i've got
just one proposal on the table it's been
seconded can i just ask a question i was
slightly
puzzled when i i read this and i saw uh
councillor hodson
finance internal audit and coastal
protection
i'm not sure how they sit together very
well so
if we're going to vote on councillor
mcgoffs
motion about the environment i'm sure
coastal protection must come under
but anyway uh right councillor mcgoff i
don't know if you want to say anything
before we go to the vote
how much time into um you all heard it
loud and clear i think steve is the best
man for the job and thanks very much to
stacey for clarifying the position
within the constitution um like it's got
to stand in its own right the
environment it's such so important and
steve to me is the person for the job
thank you
i've now got more speakers who would say
so uh councillor leather
thank you chair yeah well it's been
proposed and seconded to accept that
list on page 24.
i'm not sure now whether this is an
amendment that counselor mcguff's
putting forward
or a fresh uh proposition
um but i think if we're looking at
separating out
the environment from what's listed there
um as i think with councillor pennington
said we really ought to let
all the councillors put the name
forwards if they'd like to take this
role on
if we decided to separate it but i've
got to say i do have some sympathy with
councillor ames
he is lead member for the climate change
and biodiversity
and i would have thought the environment
fits in with that to be honest
so uh i i'm happy with the the list is
printed on page 24.
chair thank you thank you uh oh gosh
i've got so many hands up now
councillor james right thank you
uh chair can i just come back um
why some of the logic behind what we've
done if you look at um
as council hodgson said earlier in the
meeting um
now in the other meeting um she did have
multiple roles and because finance is so
important we've actually
i don't know that's the right word send
cancer hush and down to
dealing with finance in in terms of
the climate um though she uh
council holston already sits on uh
committee to do with
um the climb sorry coastal
uh erosion and stuff like that and we
are working with north devon or we will
be working with north devon
about coastal uh flooding and
in protection that will go in with the
planning
uh situation it's something that come up
at the local plan issue
so actually um i would imagine claire
has got slightly less to do
and certainly it doesn't make a lot of
difference to me i don't think
but in my role as environment the only
things i really dealt with
was basically janet and dog poo
and also the dealings with
uh nap hoes that was my main two
contributions
i think it's a bit of a confusion about
what is environment
and what is environment protection
because much of the environment stuff
is now slipping into the planning
department especially to do with um
stuff like ammonia emissions and stuff
like that
so you know we were in danger of just
going back to where we were having a lot
of members
dealing with um officers
and just complicating it i've got no
particular view other than
we did try to simplify it so the
officers
knew who they were dealing with and i
think i would have liked to have just
been able to got some definition
of exactly what counselors see is the
difference between environment
and environmental protection um but i i
go with the flow
i do see a lot of it comes under
councillor haines
a lot of it um in terms of recycling and
all that sort of stuff in terms of
environment
will come under council of leather but
that's only my view i'm open to what the
rest of the councillors think
thank you thank you uh council of laws
thank you chair uh chair we
seem to be suddenly finding ourselves in
new ground here with people's names
coming out of the hand but very capable
names too i might add
and it would seem to me that the
appropriate time to do this
is it the agm because that will give
people time to think
put their names forward if they wish uh
we
it does look a very traditional list at
the moment
with people just taking over
um but there that's going to be
for the councillors to decide in a few
minutes i would just
like to mention um councillor hodgson's
role
on coastal uh the coastal matters
she's traveled the country representing
this council
very uh ably on this she's it
really uh embraced it works well with
the offices
and is we need very good representation
now talking with north devon because it
has
huge implications uh on them
uh more than us in a way but then we've
got the
the tip to address and she's very
capable
and very well versed on those subjects
so
i support her on that i'm just wondering
whether we're jumping in here
tonight putting names forward suddenly
uh when
we should at least consider for one
meeting but i think may
may would be the time to do it thank you
thank you council laws you haven't
actually proposed that it's just a
suggestion so i'll go on to next count
enough proposals i think we need to hear
from
what happened councillor jones
thank you chair um one thing that just
sort of stuck up for me was everyone
seems to be
referring to the environment as creating
a creating a new role
um counselor james already is the lead
member for environment so it wouldn't be
creating a new role as such it would
just be
ensuring that that role continues and
potentially we
redefine it um i think
as um councilman mcguff i think
councillor harding is
is well versed in this and is someone
that can bring
something different to the table but has
that experience and and passion for this
area
and would do it would do a damn good job
of it the only thing that i
um would say as as everyone but as um
as has already been noted not being at
all a slight on on councillor hodgson
um who would obviously still be the
deputy leader and or still have that
influence on
coastal matters but i do wonder whether
it would make more sense now if we are
doing this tonight to shift the coastal
uh
mata into the environment portfolio and
i wonder whether any whether councilman
mcgoff would want to
include that in his proposal for making
councillor harding
um our our lead on the environment
that's all thank you
thank you uh councillor hudson
well thank you very much um just to
answer
councillor jones his comments about
moving the coastal services the element
of my
proposed role into
the environment the work i've been doing
since i was elected has
been quite in-depth working with various
agencies
with the environment agency with regards
to our problems at
westwood ho and the ridge working
nationally with
the environment agency at a much higher
level to try
and unpack the opportunities for
north devon and uh torridge
with regard to future funding that may
become available for us
um so i would be reluctant to let that
go
because i think we are actually making
headway
we have actually got torridge on the map
i did a presentation at the last
special interest group that is chaired
by
the chief exec of
sorry the leader of the council at
newcastle
and did a presentation alongside a lot
of the coastal
issues all around the country and people
now know where torridge is which
um regrettably didn't have a very high
level profile but they do now so i'd be
reluctant to see that go
at the moment if uh when we get this
group started with north devon
um you find that in may
you want to rearrange the
lead member roles then i think that
would be the perfect opportunity
for us to actually make our bids for
whatever we have got
key interests in because i dare say
there will be some competition
for some of these lead member roles and
i think we need to evidence
who is best suited and if i'm not found
suitable then i will step down and
pass over the reins to someone else but
at the moment i
think consistency and continuity until
may
we ought to carry on with the slightly
amended version that we have before us
tonight
thank you thank you i've just got one
last final speaker
councillor james all right thank you
chair um
i don't want to get personalities what i
will say on the coastal stuff
is if you go back a year or so torbay
was leading the discussions about
coastal erosion and all that sort of
stuff
and there was no mention at all of
anything in north devon
including north devon as well as
torridge councillor hodson's been to
meetings in london
she has fought hard um almost
the point of embarrassment sometimes
well yes made it
quite clear that you know coastal
erosion does happen in north devon
and that we should have representation
and so i would be very reluctant to lose
claire
she didn't actually know i was putting
her name down in that form
we did discuss what we were going to do
with it and when we drew the list up
i just typed her name in there because i
feel it's so
important that when she goes to these
meetings when she fights for
um westwood ho and the prospects
if if the climate change happens
as they're predicting in terms of um
the raising of the water levels and the
intensity of storms
we are going to have real problems um in
the future
um and so we do need some connection
continuity there so i would really um
i would rather give up my role than see
claire give up hers
simple as that thank you chad my chair
it's casella forward here i'm going to
wait up help me out
can i have a minute sorry you don't put
your hand up counselor forward no i
don't want to push the right button
i've also got uh steve hurst wanting to
speak now
um i'll let councillor ford say
something then i will end with uh
steve if that's all right councillor
ford no thanks chair
appreciate that uh yeah a lot of good
sense then we need to reach out anyway
and um
i think um i've had conversations with
all
different political parties over the
last few days um
probably it doesn't need to be left till
may um
i don't think we're totally flush with
talents of the bit we've got i think we
ought to use
i've always believed in that being
consistent even the last time i was me i
i don't
want any role myself whatsoever um
i mean for example and i'll keep it
brief i'm glad mr lawrence is laughing
because we need a bit of sensory
in these difficult times um but we have
got to use the talent that we have got
we got a draw on it
and i've made suggestions about future
going forward with planning never mind
personalities and the people
that know i've spoken about six people
last 48 hours
know what i'm talking about and again i
want no role myself but when i see
certain people on free committees
um when quite frankly you know i might
not even think they got any talent for
any
any one of us three i i think it's very
sad i'll give one example you might be
embarrassed
um deputy leader from last time
he's a lead member um of the previous
council
honourable man not my necessarily i'm an
independent if somebody's uh
red i'll flag them all for playing a
role with a blue old swag them off
i'm consistent in that but i tell him i
i recognized recently he wasn't on any
committee at all
it's tragic we've got a pool of
resources we've got
and what i will say is as i did from day
one i don't like somebody been in a post
forever
i don't think that's healthy i don't
think the public thinks it's healthy by
the way
but when you're dealing with licensing
and planning it's non-political
and i um will say now that
the best two people in planning i will
pick up my email uh forward but it needs
to be resolved at agm
is roselock and mr christie peter
christie the chair
we got you know they'll know more than
i'll ever know about planning no matter
whether i like them
probably don't want to drink them they
probably don't want to drink with me
that's not an issue
let's use a bit of talent we've got
thank you very much
thank you council report uh steve i'm
here
okay thanks chair just just a couple of
words i'm not gonna obviously not gonna
comment on any of the recommendations or
anything made other than to say i think
it's clear that
if uh members do determine to have a
lead member for the environment then
that will
clearly need to be properly articulated
because as being said it does cross over
some of the other
lead member roles i think the other
thing that's key to to resolve quite
quickly is making sure that as officers
we've got
um a clear line with lead members
because your
officer team are currently preparing the
service plans
and part of the proposal is obviously as
usual sharing those
with the lead members and bringing
information back to leadership
um so it's quite clear and critical that
we want to push ahead with
the service planning because obviously
we've lost quite a considerable amount
of time with the pandemic
we want to push ahead with a strategic
plan and with the the other plans the
council has so it's obviously quite
clear
where we want to want to move forward
with those roles as quickly as we can
thank you well there's two votes here
there's uh council magos
i'm going to take it as an amendment and
take it first because it was proposed
and it was seconded
uh i take on board what uh steve just
said that something the officer is going
to have to hammer out after the vote if
it goes
uh in favor of councilman goff
uh right i'll go to the vote it's been
proposed being segmented by councilman
goff that
um councillor harding becomes a lead
member of her environment
uh mary can you do the voting yes sir
councillor balton uh four
cancer bride against
councillor brown four
councillor bushby against
councillor christie against
councillor clark or
against councillor dart
against councillor ford
against councillor cup
against councillor hackett
against councillor haines
against councillor harding
for councillor hawkins
against councillor hudson
against councillor hurley
four councillor jinx
four councillor inch
uh four councillor james
councillor jones for
councillor langford against
council of laws against
mackenzie against
councillor manley against
councillor newton four
councillor pennington
council of watson
councillor watson
again both against thank you councillor
wiseman
i'm against thank you
chair that's 12 4 21 against
and one of abstention thank you well
that's lost
uh we go back to the um previous
uh motion this was the one that's
actually on the agenda tonight
uh that we accept the lead member
structure and the lead members i set out
on page 24.
um i think councillor james proposed it
and i
can't remember who seconded it but i
think it has been seconded is that right
mary
councillor bushby i believe thank you
all right if we go to the vote on that
one as well now
yep thank you council about and
at four councillor bright
four councillor brown moore
councillor bushby or
councillor christie or councillor clark
or councillor hunkin
or councillor craigie
for councillor dart
for councillor ford well it makes it
easy
four councillor cup
four council hackett
four councillor haines abstain
councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or
councillor apple
against
council inch for
councillor james or
councillor jones against
councillor langford or
councillor laws
council laws
paul sorry thank you that's okay
four until the law oh
councillor mackaff against
council mackenzie
four councillor manly
for councillor newton
four
council watson four
council of wise men four
thank you chair that's 29 four and five
against
thank you that's carrie then wait we'll
move go back to the agenda
uh move on to item 10 uh the carbon
plans and this
i think has been taken by janet williams
that's right thank you very much chair
thank you uh good evening ladies and
gentlemen um just a single report from
me covering
uh two aspects and first very quickly
to update members on the progress of our
own carbon plan
uh just to let you know that the draft
plan has been written
and was approved at the last meeting of
the member
climate emergency working group so that
will be brought to the next full council
meeting for review
and hopefully approval and but the main
part of this report
um is around the recommendations from
the member climate working group in
response to devon county council's
consultation on their interim carbon
plan so the links to the plan as well as
a summary document
are provided in the report and i hope
members have had a chance to
read at least a summary um interim
carbon plan
and this was reviewed and discussed at
the last working group meeting
and they've recommended for approval by
full council the responses that are
given in the report
and these relate to concerns proposed
time skills for reaching net zero
in the county and not sufficiently
challenging that more emphasis
is needed to enhance digital
connectivity across all of our
communities
and that there is stronger commitment
given to active travel and cycling
infrastructure
and that the exploration of energy
production utilizing tidal energy
be explored in the river torridge and so
those are the recommendations
of the climate emergency working group
which are put forward for endorsement by
full council
and myself or councillor holmes as
chairman of the of the member group
are happy to answer any questions chair
thank you
thank you very much uh brilliant short
report thank you
um councillor haynes you're first
um yes thank you yeah i'd just like to
congratulate
janet williams for producing this um
very well written plan
he's taken on board what has been
discussed
through through the year since the
working group was formed
um there were one or two
changes suggested as janet has said
um i think there were one or two more
actually
in terms of what should be included like
um
a map of sea level likely sea level rise
and also a breakdown of carbon emissions
within devon in terms of localities
and also we talked about um
possibly um changing the structure at
the end of the plan about the actions
possibly putting him in tabular form
um we haven't actually got a written
report so i'm not sure whether we're
actually
voting on this or just being invited to
hear what has happened
certainly um i would urge all
councillors to read the
plan and to input their comments
uh so that we can look at them at the
next working group
and to finally produce um
a final draft plan for approval by full
council
um that's all i want to say thank you
thank you councillor inch
i have got an interest i am the um a
county councillor
um so if that can be noted please but
just to say that um
i'm not on this working group actually
and uh being
the only devon county councillor on
storage
i wonder if i could be included actually
in the working group
i think that may be important um
also you know i think that uh
to say that um we're not
doing enough and 2050 is
is going to be uh too little you know
um and not going far enough like
2030 is the um there's a date that
torridge has uh
set um you know
demon county council i think has set a
realistic
uh date 2015. that doesn't mean to say
that we were going to take until 2050 to
do everything we want to do
that's just the time set and i think
that um perhaps
you know torridge have to look at their
own plan i think and concentrate on
their own plan
um before they start me i know it's a
constitution and um
but um you know
demon county council are and have and
have been making
lots of um lots of
uh going forward they've done lots of
plans
for planting trees in their um
in their farms that they own uh 10 000
acres of farmland they own and
we are trying to um
tackle the climate change but to say
that
2050 is too late i think
it's torridge is a bit wrong saying that
because
that's just the that's just a mark on on
a calendar
that it doesn't mean to say that we're
going to have to take until 2050 to do
all we
are going to do and if we do make 50
change by 2030
i think that will go a long way
um okay chair
thank you uh councillor lock yeah i've
just got one query on page 26
the last bullet point of the first
paragraph
where it talks about a project of
exploring energy
generation within the tidal flows
i mean during my time on the council i'm
sure i can remember two
occasions when projects or suggestions
have been put forward
and it's always come back that the um
tides or the estuary are not suitable
for any tidal energy so i just wondered
what the point wasn't included in that
sure and i just come in there because um
some years ago we had a gentleman
actually talked to torres about this
and this was about an idea about a dam
across the estuary mouth
um he did when he was queried about this
about the uh
how he would anchor a dam um
he did suggest that we might have to
concrete over a third of the pebble
ridge
to hold it in place this side and on the
biosphere
i think i i had to hold andy bell back
who was extremely upset the idea of
building a huge ban
um i was going to query this but i think
there might be a possibility of micro
generation clearly i wouldn't like our
officers to waste time looking at a dam
across the street mouse because that's
never going to happen
micro uh production might happen anyway
uh
councillor bushby sorry point of order
chair sorry
are we my understanding is we're still
talking about the
torridge district council plan the
points which cancer locks raise relates
to the
county council plan and also councillor
um inch um i didn't think we'd moved on
to the next item
yet perhaps i'm mistaken oh i thought we
had i thought uh
janet williams uh bundled them together
but uh
sorry uh i'll come back i'll come back
to that possibly but councillor bushby
thank you chair well coaster lock is
touched upon this exactly the same
bullet point that i was going to make
and my question was going to be you know
has there been a budget
um set aside to
even explore energy generation because
you know energy tidal energy generation
even in even in its exploratory form
you know could prove to be you know very
very
costly very expensive operation so i
just wonder whether
you know there's been any figure set
aside
i haven't seen anything in the budget to
actually push a thing like that forward
otherwise it's it's merely words
otherwise
right uh janet can i ask you to just
answer that
yeah if i can come back on that chair
and this is response to the
the county's um interim carbon plan
so it would be a recommendation that the
county
um carry out such a project so we had no
budget for that and it wouldn't be
something that our officers would be
doing
it's purely a response to the county
a suggestion that they look at um as has
been mentioned
and the the new technologies and the new
opportunities that might be available i
am aware of that report that you cited
councillor christie
and i don't think that would be suitable
but technology is developing all the
time
and it's not something that's been
captured in the in the devon plans so
it's just something that we think
would be uh would be useful to to to
consider
thank you i have um other counsellors
wishing to speak but i've also got uh
steve hurst has put his hand up i'll
call him first if that's all right
um chairs only just briefly janet
answered most of it
but it was just in response to something
councillor hayes mentioned
so we're not talking about torridge
torridge's climate plan
at all this evening janet was briefly
updating that
come back to the next full council
meeting so it was only
the devon county uh carbon plan
that you're dealing with
thank you um councilman mckenzie
oh thank you um i was just going to come
back to the county councillors um
admirable defense of county um
but 2050 isn't a realistic target 2030
is what the eminent scientist and
obviously david attenborough if you've
seen any of the
um documentaries on this subject
and time's running out and they don't
seem to have the sense of urgency that
you know we need to instill into them um
you know
this is good that the county council is
sticking up for the council but
you know he's got a duty to the people
of torridge
as well so thank you thank you
councillor craig here
thank you chair um i just wanted to make
a couple of points about the
the title energy i was at cnr this
morning
and we were talking about the post covid
economic recovery plan
and um the need to generate you know
some
some new industries and new income
for our area well we've got some
wonderful resources
mainly of water the wind
the river and with so many opportunities
now it
i don't think it would have to be our
investment at all
there are companies who are looking for
sites
to do um trials of tidal energy and they
are micro
tidal um they would hardly be visible
because they'd be underneath the water
and they they just need a boy on the top
just so you avoid them
um and i think we we've got to look at
this
you know we're not in a rich area we
haven't got a lot of industry
and if the government's going for you
know
growing back greener better bigger
bolder
i would have thought we were one of the
best places to do it
in and the in the devon plan it does
actually mention apple door ship yard
being suitable for building marine
technology
so that could be tidal wave offshore
wind
could be any number and i would remind
the the councillors who
are not really in favor of
wind turbines that the the plan that
devon
is putting forward is utilizing
wind turbines and solar panels
now unless they want you want to see
fields of solar panels which i don't
or onshore wind turbines
then we need to go for alternatives and
putting things offshore is a brilliant
way to
do it it would hardly be visible at all
with the new technology
and i i would really strongly recommend
it because it would bring in
skilled jobs it would bring in wealth it
will be
bringing new companies and and
it could be environmental as well that
today
they're not developing these new
technologies
um to be intrusive or you know against
the environment
they're building them to fit into the
environment
and to work with it so i don't think we
need to be afraid of them
but i'm just warning you that if we
don't go for things like this
we'll be losing a big opportunity
especially for biddeford i
i want to find some opportunities for
biddeford and this is really one of them
and the harbour board was in favor at
one point of
developing tidal so i'm hoping that you
the rest of you might be too
thank you thank you uh council of the
laws
uh yes well i mean biddeford
has the most wonderful opportunity i'll
give you the fours and then i'll
damn it because if we could put it down
across where the new bridge is
so we had a constant lagoon upstream
what a wonderful place biddeford would
be you put your tidal energy
into the into that dam you can't do that
because we're a port we have about two
boats a year
and that dams that idea it really is
time we changed our
attitude we've got to be free thinking
i've lived here for 75 years and
yesterday i saw the biggest waves
i have ever seen crashing into the
pebble ridge
things are changing now and we have to
change now
and we have to think to the future thank
you
thank you council of laws uh some of us
did suggest that
uh they put um some tidal energy under
the new barnstable bridge
they don't get any boats at all but it
was turned down
uh i'll go on council hudson thank you
very much
um i'm really interested to see
the proposals and needless to say that
final bullet point about
energy generation uh and what it could
do um
with the estuaries and the rivers all
this
obviously um could work
together with the coastal protection
work uh
joint working that we are proposing with
north devon because
the other identified partner for this uh
discussion is uh devon county council
because of the landfill
site now if we are in a place where we
talk about
where we can find funding and what kind
of um
inc on this could potentially generate
the jobs it could do whether these two
projects
could dovetail together would be
something i think would that would be
worth exploring
and at least having within the terms of
reference
and bringing devon county in uh
to the discussions and i'd like to sort
of further this with
our own district council carbon plan
so i'm putting out a
hand of friendship to work together and
not
in isolation because we don't want to be
developing
one project to address flooding
coastal flooding the estuary flooding
issues
and another one working on
energy generation i think the two could
work together
as a a major project and probably
attract more innovation funding than
one on their own thank you
thank you councillor pennington just
declare a personal interest chair
because if it's offshore a win
they may wish to bring it a cross ground
the atlantic array cost me enormous
difficulties last time
so i just declare a personal interest at
this point there's nothing on the plan
but
cover my back thank you thank you uh
councillor holmes
oh thank you chad um yeah i'm in
sympathy with
obviously all other sorts of alternative
energy but that's been
it's been pointed out there was a study
done on north origin there
were identified problems i mean one of
the problems is the effect on
wildlife and biodiversity given that um
the history is an ssi
in the river um but i'm all in favor of
looking at like
they did experiments at lin linmus
didn't they using for tidal energy
about 10 20 years ago and britain this
country was in the
it was an advance in pursuing that form
of energy
but um and also one could pursue
small-scale hydro schemes
across courage so i think those things
are well worth looking at
but having said that
offshore wind and solar are now
tried and tested technologies which are
coming down in
price year by year and
particularly offshore wind is
contributing a huge amount
to electricity generation in this
country
it could also provide jobs at appledore
shipyard if such a thing was developed
off our coast
so i think we need to recognize that
really
thank you thank you i've got no more
speakers i'll go to the recommendation
on page 27
um i'll propose we accept that is there
a second there
yeah i didn't
sorry i didn't see who that was
counselor watson chess
and thank you right mary can we go to
the vote
yes chair council about four
councillor bright for
councillor brown or
councillor bush b or councillor christie
or councillor clark or
councillor cottle hankin or
elsa craigie or councillor dart
for councillor ford or
councillor cub or
councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or fall
council harding or councillor hawkins
or councillor apple
or councillor hicks
again
inch against
councillor james or
councillor jones or
councillor langford your counselor laws
or council of leather or
councillor lock or councillor mcgolf
or council mackenzie
four councillor manly
for councillor newton
four councillor pennington
or councillor watson
oh councillor wiseman
or jer that's 32 4 and 2
2 against thank you all right we'll go
back to the agenda
uh item 11 procedural rules
and um david hayes is going to take this
it's split into two sections you see
um david if you can do the first section
and then briefly stop and i'll see if
there are any questions then we'll go on
to the second
section again we'll have any questions
at the end uh there is only one vote for
both though so
if you can carry on david
thank you chair um i've actually got a
british presentation it is only five
slides don't worry it's not like one of
my normal budget presentations
is there any chance tommy could make
that a little bit bigger on screen for
me please
so thank you
so what is the purpose of the financial
and contractual procedure rules why do
we have
them well it protects the organization
by limiting the liability that the
actions of one
individual can cause the council it sets
limits on the value of purchase orders
for example that an individual officer
can raise
it formalize it formalizes the
responsibilities of individual
postholders
and it provides the staff with guide
rules and guidance as how they should
act
hopefully it protects the council from
financial loss
and it ensures that the council operates
in an equitable manner and that
contracts are awarded based on objective
measurable criteria
it defines the delegated authority of
officers
this should be our finance and contract
procedure rules should be
flexible for the real world situation
such as urgency procedures so
members of community and resources that
this morning at the meeting would have
had some urgency procedures
and they're detailed in our finance and
contract procedurals and our
constitution
and it ensures that the key decisions
are approved by elected members
and it provides a control environment
which mitigates
doesn't eliminate but mitigates the risk
as fraud and loss
let's fly please tom
okay just make it a little bit bigger
please stop thank you so
what happens when finance and contract
procedurals are beat
are aren't efficiently robust the
follicle challenge gentleman is actually
nick leeming he's the chat who brought
down bearings bank
and they had one of their procedures was
he was actually allowed to check his own
trades
rather than go to a supervisor that's
obviously a weakness in their
procedurals which allowed him to build
up losses that weren't being checked and
validated
and the little symbol where two men are
sat at a table that's money going under
the table
for awarding a contract and credit card
we have rules about how our officers use
credit cards what they can spend the
money on and the controls and checks
that we put in place
obviously one you know in a in the old
days when we were very much a cash
centered in
um industry you'd have rules about
making sure that the safe was locked at
all times and that
um it had petty cash and he was getting
the box to give him something else to
assign for so that's
what happens cover the next slide please
tom
so what do our finance and contract
procedure rules cover well they defined
the limits for staff for ordering goods
and service on behalf of the council
they set limits for the company credit
cards and defines what documentation is
required in support of expense claims
it sets the levels at which the council
needs to go out to tender
and how the tender process would work it
sells delegated authority levels for
officers
right in terms of amount of debt which
can be written off by an officer
versus the level at which authorities
sought from elected members
outlines the circumstances which office
can act outside of the finance and
contractual procedures such as
urgency decisions or contract waivers
for example
defines some segregation of duties and
has controls on setting assession up
employees on the council's payroll
the financial contract procedurals that
we're hope discussing tonight
are also backed up by individual service
areas procedural so actually within my
section of finance we have our own
procedure rules which
provide in a greater level of detail
than actually detailed in the finance
and contract procedure rules
of the next five fees tom
so why are the finance and contract
procedure rules being updated well
put very simply the environment which
the council operates changes
we've got a new payroll system for
example and it's electronic submissions
of
expense claims and travel claims rather
than paper claims
cash receipting has essentially stopped
within the council with the exception of
the borrowers
and we need to do some general
housekeeping changing job titles for
example we no longer no longer have a
head of paid service we have a chief
executive and changes in legislation
for example ir 35 legislation
gave us rules about how
their tax status essentially and whether
they were fulfilling a council vacancy
and we obviously have done things like
dental data protection
and of course we let brexit we've left
the european union there's some
contract procedure rules which are dated
to our time and we members of the
european union which have now been
superseded
i will bring to members attention that
the post changes the finance and
contract procedurals were approved and
recommended to full council by the audit
and governance committee back in july
2020 and unfortunately
um i'd like this report to come to full
council earlier but
you've had some very full agendas and
this um
report has been moved from a few earlier
meetings on i think two occasions now so
i do apologize that there's been such a
gap
through being recommended by our
colleagues on audit and governance
committee before it comes to
all council uh i want to take the vote
as an as a whole and chairman rather
than in two individual
components so the recommendation to full
council is it approves the proposed
change is detailed in the report
to both the finance and contract
procedure rules i believe council
hodgson may just want to say a few words
at this point
thank you
david as ever a very detailed document
which i've spent many hours i think i
must have read this at least
three times um there have
uh as you heard david's reference to yes
we do have some
cash payments that we actually receive
uh
from the borrower's toll so it
is with that exception um my
only i am happy to recommend
all the documentation in front of you
tonight
uh with subject to a very small
amendment
where it regards uh with regard to the
disposal of land
up to ten thousand pounds we
actually when drafting the changes
agreed that ward members should be
consulted so that was added
but the trouble is ward members just
being consulted doesn't actually
we could be told something that a piece
of land
up to the value of ten thousand pounds
was being disposed of
but it doesn't actually give us any uh
remit to agree or disagree
so i would propose an amendment that
board members
agree the disposal and if they fail to
agree
then it's referred to cnr okay that's
your
subject matter i'm second
second thank you we'll come back to that
vote in a minute
um i have got one speaker before we get
that can i just ask
one question on david's slides there
uh there's something about um right off
of debts
now they're all that's always extremely
contentious and i've sat in meetings
where this has gone on for a long time
discussing this
but i was surprised to see that
apparently there's some level
below which officers can write off debts
um can i ask when would councillors be
aware of that
i think all proposed writers should
actually come to
councillors i mean this is public money
we're talking about
and for officers just to write it off um
i'm not quite
certain that acceptable can i just ask
david about that
what is the level well there's details
within that i mean just for example i
have authority
um council custody to offer a night off
of
say within council tax which they have
to say a thousand pounds
i can't remember that level i can check
but
if you were to get every debt that we're
done so we could have a debt
of say 25 pound on a car parking ticket
fine that we gave
we've gone to try and establish who that
person is and have failed he's gone to
bayless
um the person could be dead and it's
very you know
relatively low values of money so what
happens is there's limits in those
finance procedures to
have when it's a large amount of debt
over certain limits and i'll go
i'll try to find the relevant section in
the report there's equals to the
um is it's clr to write off the actual
debt
i mean when you say all debt i mean some
debts can be exceptionally small
councillor christie
well thank you for that david but uh you
all know that uh the smaller the amount
the longer the arguments in councils
um i'd actually like to see a list of
these because i'm sorry but
uh you know we are dealing with public
money here
and they may be small we could take them
on block but
i'm certain that there are some which
would uh raise queries but uh
anyway i'll go on councillor hackett
yes thank you chair um just to say as
chairman of auditing governance
i've seen both these reports uh
year in year out for my tenure
and they have been thoroughly scrutin
scrutinized by the committee
so i have no problem at all in
recommending that we support them
thank you thank you
uh councillor newton yeah i was just
going to say
um that uh
i i think also we see them uh councillor
pennington will
will uh sorry councillor watson will
will correct me if not but we also
see a list of these under uh oversight
uh uh and scrutiny internal committee
uh i've certainly seen a list of of of
debtors which have been written off uh
in that committee so that we we do
scrutinize
certainly you write this on
we do have it to own us internally
thank you uh councillor hodson yeah just
sorry just to come back quickly
i think there is a point where we do
have to give a delegation to
officers for writing off small
or debts i recognize what you're saying
council of christie about it being
public money
but audit and the processes for writing
off these debts
would scrutinize a percentage of those
to ensure that
it was written off appropriately after
the appropriate action
has been taken so i think rather than
clogging ourselves up
we have to recognize that certain roles
have to be delegated to officers
but they aren't uh unchecked
thank you thank you uh steve hurst
um chair i think councillor hodgson
covered more most of what i was going to
say
and i think if you had every item of
debt
presented to members you'd have it on
every committee meeting
because david mentioned you know we've
got tens pounds
very small amounts and they are
thoroughly audited there is a formal
procedure and process which goes for
through and all the documentation is
there for
our internal and external auditors who
look at
all of those processes thank you
um right i'll go to the vote nobody else
wishes to speak
um as somebody proposed
we accept these i think reports
that's right yes thank you um right we
had uh
councillor hudson you had a an amendment
i think you wanted
if you want to go over that uh yes i'd
like to amend
um the section under disposal of land
value up to 10 000 pounds and i'm sorry
i've been reading it online and my
actual
paper copy i can't find it was
page 82 i believe online
32 on paper 32 and paper thank you very
much councillor watson
um
that sounds right uh
sorry i'm dithering here right
my proposal is to add
um
it's been changed on my copy here
if ward members are not in agreement
with the decision to dispose the
decision
yes but i think it it is there actually
yes you're quite right
so we don't actually need the amendment
it is within the government
i i do apologize you know what i've been
doing i've been reading the online
version
i've commented to uh
david hayes about changing this and he's
preempted
it so thank you david i'm dumped myself
right in it again
because i haven't read my paper copy so
i stepped in and actually apologized to
you council hudson because actually i
think
i shouldn't perhaps have changed it
because of course the
audit and governance didn't approve that
recommendation so
um you you should have been proposing an
amendment and that's my error
so please accept my apologies
we're all apologizing to each other so
as long as we get it right
um i'd like to apologize to my ordinary
government committee members because
i've changed one of their
recommendations inadvertently and i do
apologize to them
oh david thank you that's a problem
david
right so i'll go to the vote then
yeah uh mary can you take the vote yes
council abouten four
council bright
council brown or councillor bushby
or council christie or
council clark or
councillor cottle hankin or
counselor craigie or
cancer dart for
councillor ford or
councillor cup for
councillor hackett or councillor haines
orb answer harding
for council hawkins
or councillor
for councillor hicks
or councillor hudson
four councillor hurley
or councillor hatchings
james or
councillor jones or
councillor langford four
council littles or
cancel a data or
cancel a lock or cancel them a golf
councilman mcgover
mcgrath seems to be just joining i think
oh i'll come back shall i councillor
mckenzie
or councillor manley
or councillor newton
for councillor pennington
councillor watson or
councillor wiseman or
has councilman rejoined yes he has
yeah so i think he can hear us be aware
of what he's voting on
maybe not hey can you hear us counseling
off
no there's no response
would you like each other to phone him
again
chair that's 33 4. thank you
right we going on then uh are there any
petitions
item 12 on the agenda no chair no
well we go on to the last item on the
agenda then uh notice a motion from
councillor home so council haynes if you
wish to speak
thank you um yeah
just a short statement here to introduce
this motion
uh recent progress reports of the
parliamentary committee on climate
change has stated that the uk government
is seriously behind meeting its target
of net achieving net zero emissions by
2050
in its sixth report in december 220 the
committee stated that to meet the target
there needs to be urgent action
to achieve an 80 reduction in carbon
emissions by 2035.
apart from significant reductions in
emissions from the energy sector mainly
due to phasing out coal the committees
found that not nearly enough has been
done by government in other sectors to
meet the challenges of climate change
recently for example
britain compares badly with funding for
green recovery
from the pandemic allocating three
billion pounds compared with
germany's 36 billion and france's 14
billion pounds
the results of a recent international
opinion poll on climate change carried
out by the united nations and involving
1.2 million people
in 50 countries were that on average
two-thirds supported urgent climate
action
but significantly in the uk this figure
was 81
it is cl it is this clear gap between
what ordinary people think should be
happening regarding the climate and what
our government is actually doing that
has been reflected in this proposed
climate and ecological emergency bill
this is why i urge you in common with
north devon district council
to support the motion i put on the
agenda
our council is playing its part with
other councils and organizations
throughout the country
to reduce carbon emissions but it is
national government action which is the
most vitally needed to implement
urgent measures to reduce greenhouse
emissions
so far the government has disastrously
failed to put forward a clear route map
with detailed emergency plans and how we
can reach
the 1.5 degree target beyond which the
extreme
weather associated with climate change
could eventually make our planet
uninhabitable
i've circulated the bill to you and set
out the highlights which
include incorporating so-called imported
emissions
from uk trade with china and other
countries
incorporating a mission of some aviation
and shipping
protecting and restoring biodiversity
and establishing a citizen's assembly to
work with government
with our support and that of other
councils and organizations it is to be
hoped that the bill would become law
and will thereby strengthen the 2008
climate change act
and ensure that britain puts in place a
comprehensive
and enforceable strategy to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and restore our
natural world
i'm sure that i should add that the
bill has cross party support 77
mps thank you
thank you well i'll second it from the
chair um i did clear this with
uh steve hurst before the meeting that
we can actually talk about this and vote
on it because
the recommendation is actually um to
send a letter
um to the mp
there's no financial implications as
such from this particular motion
all right i've got a lot of people
wishing to speak uh councillor newton i
think you're first
chair thank you very much um
chad i'm afraid that i cannot agree
the method been employed tonight
or albeit i do completely understand
and appreciate the passion of those
involved
and let me be absolutely clear i am not
a climate change denier at all and if
if anything um attenborough's compelling
perfect planet last night
uh really uh reinforced it very well
however i'm a district counselor
and i am not a member of a political
lobby group
and this motion is i believe
out with our competence and authority
as a district council if i want to
uh lobby politically i write as an
individual
to my member of parliament we as
a district council are not responsible
for voting for or returning our local mp
to parliament that is for the electorate
as individuals
and i am did not stand on a ticket to be
a member of a an electoral
lobby group and indeed i would object to
being hijacked
to be as such so i'm afraid i will not
be able to support this
although i would reinforce that i am
absolutely as concerned as anybody else
about climate change but not through
this
route thank you uh thank you councillor
newton i would just point out the
council has actually written on quite a
few times to the mp on
national aspects which do affect orange
yes
and i don't believe that that's correct
and the last time we did it on the on
the agricultural bill
again we we would be better
concentrating on things we have control
over
right you are thank you uh councillor
wiseman you're next
thank you chad i didn't realize that's
quite my turn um right yes
well at face value this seems like a
very good idea doesn't it
we've clearly we're not acting quickly
enough um there's not
uh it's quite frightening the prospects
that are presenting themselves to us um
but
i've read through it all i've had some
representation
um in emails but interestingly from
people who live in biddeford
nobody from my ward i don't know why
i've read through it
and it it seems a little somewhat
wishy-washy
to be perfectly honest um we've got to
account for
co2 produced in other countries
producing goods are sent here we've got
to one take it
or minimize or reduce damage to nature
in supply chains i assume that means
we're going to extend our reach to other
countries in that manner as well
i wonder actually if we're going to take
account of co2 produced elsewhere if if
we produce
um goods for export does that mean we
don't have to
count the co2 we produce that's that's
another nation's problem
and i've also got a big problem with the
idea of a
people's uh a citizen assembly
um i always remember that uh it was
a public consultation that came up with
the name boaty mcboatface
you have to be a little bit careful i
assume that authors of this bill
should naturally assume that people on
the public on the uh
citizens assembly would agree with them
but there's every chance that it would
just bog down into paralysis
with with the citizens assembly wishing
to please everyone and upset nobody
and getting nowhere there's a very real
chance that this will actually
slow down and possibly harm
our reducing co2 and i am mindful of the
fact that
we aren't a political lobby group and
that gives me some trouble as well i
don't see how i can support this
thank you councillor jones
thank you chair i think hit the nail on
the head with this one
i think there are fundamentally two
things going on here
one is the substantive content of the
bill itself
which has merits albeit i don't think
that many but there are some merits to
it
and the fact that the bill is being this
motion is being used to lobby our mp
we've been here before we had it with
the agricultural bill we are not a lobby
group
um if you want to if members of the
public want to lobby the mp they should
write to them
as councillor newton says me i i
fundamentally believe that we have to do
something about the about climate change
there is no question about that but i
think we are doing
what we can do as accounts we've already
heard about our climate plan we've
got involved with the um
devon county consultation but i think
again we are straying
beyond beyond and we are being used here
for political ends i do take issue as
councillor wiseman has said with
with the idea of a citizens assembly it
interferes with for me what our
democracy is
we vote for someone to go to westminster
to to voice and represent the views of
their of their community
if you don't like the way they're
representing us on on
matters we hold them to account and we
vote them out
the next election the way the citizens
assembly seems to be set up
is that this will be a random selection
of people who are accountable
to nobody and will be making decisions
on our behalf or making recommendations
which will then have to be taken into
account by government
i say that doesn't really fit well with
me and i think although it may
some may say it's democratic even though
they're not selected
it certainly isn't accountable so while
i understand the passion for this
i i won't be able to support this this
evening and i hope that we can um
reduce the amount of these lobbying
motions which we seem to be getting
bogged down
at the moment thank you uh councillor
bushby
thank you
council to push me you did oh sorry
i did on luke i was saying i totally
agree with the
comments so eloquently put my country on
newton and therefore i shall be
supporting this either
thank you councillor leather
thank you chair yes i'm on the same page
as
previous speakers on this um this is a
private members bill that's going
through parliament
and if you look at some of the fellow
travelers some of the mps are supporting
it
you've got diane abbott jerry mccorbin
rebecca long bailey
tim farrenhedd david and the whole
tranche of scottish mps
um greenpeace are one of the sponsors of
it
citizens assembly we've got citizens
assembly it's called the uk parliament
but we certainly shouldn't be using this
to write to our mp i mean
it's we've just looked earlier this
evening at the torres district council
carbon plan that's where we should be
forking out focusing our effort
and not jumping on the bandwagon with
these
fellow travelers
thank you uh councillor harding
yeah just to echo uh councillors newton
and uh
jones and uh everybody else by saying
that it's not the right place to do it
even though
you know it is well thought of
thank you very much mr chairman i
totally stand by
councilman newton the council of jones
and some previous speakers there um
sorry my
internet went down uh we're not a
bluetooth lobby group on torridge
we need to focus on current issues that
we can actually change
within our own hands what we're elected
for to do so so
therefore thank you council nuisance
fully support you
thank you councillor craigie
thank you chair i do support this motion
i think that um people vote for us
to spend a lot of our time studying
politics studying
papers reading documents and
to give our best judgment on a lot of
things
and this is one thing that is so
important
we must have a view on it we must
represent the people
and we must say that we need the
government to do more about this
and the only way we can do that is write
to jeffrey cox
so i see it as the best thing that we
can do
and and i don't really i'm not really
in favor of citizens assembly myself
because i think it prolongs the process
but i think part of the reason why it's
been put forward
is to take the party political angle
out of this issue and give it back to
the people
as such people who don't have party
political
allegiances don't have an axe to grind
don't have um you know what you know
won't say that they don't like this
person or they like that person
or they follow that leader or they don't
follow you know
another leader so therefore that's the
reasoning behind
it let the people a random group of
people
come together and make the difficult
decisions
quite frankly that the politicians don't
want to make and
you'll also find that devon is having a
citizen's assembly
so if you're against them you need to be
telling the county council that as well
but um i really fully support this and
i do think we should have opinions i do
think people elect us because
the ordinary person at home hasn't got
time to read all these documents they've
got
worry about putting food on the table so
what can we do we as representatives
we can just advise what we think is the
best thing
that should be done and so therefore i
think this is
you know this is the only thing that we
can do and i think we should do it
thank you thank you uh councillor holmes
hello thank you chair um yeah
um well i seem to have opened up a quite
a
pandora's box there um if that's right
expression
um i just well i don't need to remind
this council we declared a climate
emergency
and i'm really surprised that um certain
councils think that that is a political
thing
it should be above politics and it's
such an important thing
and particularly well primarily at the
national
level it's our government which is the
main
body which is responsible for pushing
forward this the climate
agenda um so i think this
this council has a clear role in
expressing its view given that it's
declared a climate emergency
if it's concerned about what national
government is doing
um then it should say so but that will
come out in the vote
um as to um i should point out also as i
already have done that
north devon district council voted to
support the bill
contrary to certain suggestions i've
heard earlier
um just to talk about um
there's mention of imported emissions
well i mean you just go to some of the
big shops and see
the huge amount of plastic goods which
have been
trundled across the sea in containers
from china
who do you think is responsible for that
it's con people in this country who buy
these things
and we you know this should be part of
our climate
carbon emissions um account
and we you know it should be part of
government action to try and reduce that
um
the emissions resulting from that as
well as this bill
says about taking into account emissions
from aviation and
seabourn traffic i mean i don't know if
everybody really
realizes how much uh the
emissions which are generated by see
seabourn
cargo with heavy oil usage
um the other thing about climate
assembly well
i think council craigie said talk very
well about that it's not a new concept
it was used in ireland on
uh concerning the abortion bill the idea
is you
you select people by random and
they they provide um an input a popular
voice
and that this isn't in this bill the
the uh climate um the assembly wouldn't
um tell people government what to do it
would
express opinions as
input into the agenda um
and i would like to point out that as
things are
present our government and our
parliament is very much subject
to lobby groups from the oil industry
from all sectors of the economy
and particularly multinationals and i
think there was a study done a few years
ago of how often
civil servants invited
the multinationals into their offices
compared with
people like greenpeace etc it vastly
outweighed the numbers of green
of the green the green um contingent
so lobby groups and um uh
from small um interest groups related to
multinationals
are a huge problem uh for this
government
for any government actually and could
well explain why things are going so
slow
on pursuing on combating climate change
so i mean i let's put it to the vote and
and
see what people say thank you thank you
uh we put it to the vote when i've got
through the speakers there's still more
uh councillor inch
well thank you chair it was chairman
yeah i i mean
i thought back to what um country others
said really i mean
he i think he said it all really because
we do need to look as a council what
we're doing ourselves in our own
climate uh uh bill you know
uh you know there's lots of things we
can do individually
and as a council and i think to write a
letter like this
is is um i won't be supporting this at
all
because uh i agree with coach newton
that uh
it is um it is wrong
um if if we want to write to our mp we
can do it individually
but i come back to the fact that you
know there is
lots more that this council torres can
do
i mean where do we get our energy from
from start
you know that's one thing i know where i
get my energy i i get my energy from a
from a company if i'm allowed to say so
it's called bulb
as in light bulb and they and they
deal with 100 percent um
renewables and you can even uh
go on online to their group and uh
you can put in uh what how much car use
you use and all this
this is everything else and you can even
contribute uh
a payment to bulb to offset your
carbon footprint and um they will
calculate everything for you
and you know you know this is the sort
of things that i think that torridge
should be looking at how we how we use
our energy and how we look after our
environment
and how we are going to change the
climate change and everything else
we've told let's lead the way perhaps
let's
let's be a district council that does
go for 100 renewables
and then perhaps we can start to say to
to government then you know this is what
we're doing
what are you doing and i think that's
the way forward for us
thank you uh council of laws yes well
uh it sort of amazes me really because
well it's happening
that we're in terrible trouble this
planet
i mean god i know we see the wonderful
pictures from david atara
as i've said tonight i'm here at the
front edge of it
i will take any opportunity i can
yes you climate emergency yes it has a
bad
press and we don't quite like it we
don't quite trust it
but it's people like this that are going
to eventually get the message to central
government
yet they've got to act and i will
support uh councillor haines's notice of
motion
we have to do something take the
opportunity
get a letter to jeffrey cox oh might not
be quite the right way to do it i don't
care of stuff
i represent the children of this of
westwood hope
and i want to save the planet for them
and i'll shout as much as it takes
thank you chad thank you councillor
hackett
thank you chair i i can see that um on
the face of it
that um the most notification has very
laudable objectives but
the trouble is i've got to say this
bill is a cure its egg
some of it's good but there is also a
lot of bad
and this this bill has a blunderbuss
approach and can do a lot of damage so i
can't support it in its entirety
and therefore i would be going against
it for that reason
thank you uh council pennington thank
you chair
yes i i'm torn between two sides i am
totally against the citizens
assembly is set out in the bill it just
spits another layer that delays things
but there is a lot in the bill and that
i would agree with but it does concern
me in the central government
that the level of scrutiny that's
actually taken place because even their
own back benches can't get their voice
heard many of the time
and i gather that it's marcus rashford
that had the most impact
of anybody that has done things to
change things
on the school meals issue so we were
left in that situation and i
followed parliament all the way through
um on this culvert crisis a health
select committee
i'm always amazed that you've got matt
hancock
being challenged by a jeremy hunt ex uh
health secretary
and no help and social care uh select
committee
and you've got two guys in the same camp
not challenging each other so we've got
little chance
and i want to vote yes because i do want
to challenge but i am against the
citizens
assembly so i shall be voting with it
unfortunately so thank you chair for
letting me put my point in
thank you we haven't got any other
speakers um i will just say one thing on
one of the points about writing to the
mp um
i'm afraid i disagree totally with
councillor newton
and this council has written to our mp
on many occasions we've written about
wind turbines
we've written about uh coastal
protection in this area
we've uh written to him about the nhs
and the closure of our hospitals
and only last full meeting of torridge
we wrote to our mp
about bodyboards so to say that we
shouldn't is
is nonsense um anyway uh
if i can just come back on that there is
no yes
there's a subtle difference on most of
those occasions
you were informing the mp of issues
that we that were unique to us here in
torridge
this is different we're we're being
swept up
by a political lobby and the the
motivation is different
so i think it's unreasonable to compare
all of those the same but anyway
uh well i actually disagree with you
because
the nhs and wind turbines are a national
issue but anyway
it's been proposed as being second of
this vote if i can ask mary to go to the
vote
thank you abouten
against
councillor bright four
councillor brown or councillor bushby
and now i have to leave the meeting
sorry
councillor christie or
councillor clark against
councillor cottle hunkin or
councillor craigie or
councillor dart against
councillor ford or
cancel a cup against
ansel hackett against
councillor haines or councillor harding
against councillor hawkins
or councillor heppel
against councillor hicks
against councillor hudson
or councillor hurley
against councillor hutchings
against councillor inch
against councillor james
or councillor jones
against councillor langford
four council of laws
or councillor leather against
councillor locke against
councillor mcaf against
councillor manly for
councillor newton against
councillor pennington
barry you missed me out i'm sorry i i
just counted up and there wasn't a right
amount
councillor mckenzie four
chair that is 14
4 and 20 against
thank you that is the last item
on the agenda uh and before i close the
meeting i'll just point out that when
councillor brenton asked me to chair the
meeting tonight he said it won't last
long there's nothing contentious on it
right i will close a meeting thank you
all for attending and i hope to